Matt we're here at the London Film
Festival launch you've got your film
here this year tell me all about it's
your first phone isn't in fact in the
lfs this one here yeah it's called spike
island and it's a coming-of-age story
about five kids in a band at the time
with the stone roses are at their peak
and they desperate want to go and sing
Stone Roses spike islands which is going
to be the biggest gig of the year but
they can't get tickets so they have to
blag live borrow whatever they can do to
get over the barrier and through and it
goes to the heroes now it's a kind of a
spirits you've had yourself ya know for
sure I remember being at college and
having to climb over the walls at
Glastonbury and all the rest of it which
obviously is not i would recommend to
anyone i think especially now the
scooters got a bit better but remember
having to try and sneak over there's a
ladder we managed to find the first time
ever when and it was still part the bars
of the festival so it does that kind of
come across in the film how do you bring
across that buzz in the movie because
it's a very because they're live
experience isn't it well the Stone Roses
of me I never got to see the first time
around and seeing them now at Heaton
Park and we saw on the V Festival a
couple weeks ago it was amazing you know
I never thought I'd get to see them life
but I'm trying to recreate that on a
tiny budget and trying to do you know
it's trying to recreate 30,000 people in
a field on peanuts is tricky but I think
we kind of pulled it off it's having
spent most of my life going to festivals
we were really concerned to try and get
its accurately as possible and we shot a
lot of stuff from them you know we used
footage from the time we showed it to
the designer and I think I think we kind
of pulled off with a bit of visitor
fakes magic I think it kind of works and
what is it about movies like this one
that you really in love making and bring
into the big screen well since I read
the script which was a few years ago
actually I wanted to do it but I just
done a film called sex drugs and
rock'n'roll which again was a music film
and even though the two that can't
really be couldn't be more different I
just felt actually if I was my next film
it just feels like that's what I end up
doing first of my life was already being
sent every music film you know through
my agents I just I was like I'm not sure
if it's a right timing and I went and
did another film ashes with Ray Winstone
in Jim Sturgess which is which couldn't
really be more different it's a thriller
it's a road movie so then that will most
about like the antidote then I could
come back and do this so yeah it's been
it's been great it's worked out quite
well key then you had a little bit of a
rest from the music and you're back with
renewed vigor right exactly i mean i'm
the same way with documentaries and
music videos it's great to do a drama
and then go
do a documentary and every time you you
finish in the drama you never want to
see another film set you never want to
see another acting evidence to see
another crew member and you go off and
work with real people for a year by the
end of that you never want to see
another real person again in your life
you want to hang out with fake people in
the industry you know like me so yeah
it's been it's been good and the same
with music videos it's just each thing
feels like a reaction like an antidote
to the last thing you know and I think
for me it's the only way of trying to
keep yourself fresh so what you know you
obviously worked on a number of films
now what have you learnt from then that
you brought to spike island you think
well I think the main my training ground
was with revolution films with Michael
Winterbottom and Andrew Eaton's company
and I started there there was the first
job I ever had in the industry and
because they're very prolific and small
and passionate about they do in
passionate about giving people a leg up
into the industry then you know that was
that was really my film school so I've
in that sense of every time I've worked
on another film I tried to create a
similar sense of a family of trying to
help people into their first job or
second job and just take a risks on
people you know so I think that's the
main thing I'm learn from them do you
kind of tell you one of these filmmakers
you also kind of take some of the crew
on to the next film with you as a kind
of event like a kind of family yeah
right i think the tricky thing every
time you starting up a new film is
everyone has their own lives they go off
into the other jobs but if I could keep
working with this group of filmmakers
the rest of my life but be very happy
now they're they're amazing I think you
spent a long time trying to learn the
shorthand trying to hang out with people
and understand you know your likes and
your dislikes and the kind of vibe you
want on set and it takes a while to
foster that and then you know you have
to wait for the money for the next film
and people out there so available and
every time you start with a new person
as good as they might be your kind of
starting again from scratch so yeah if I
if I could care and working with the
family with creative for the rest of my
life would be very happy what's next few
you can even think about that after you
just finish this one well I was very
much hoping we'd be going on to a TV
series called gb 84 which is the next
book by david p so did the Red Riding
trilogy so we're waiting to hear back
you know so so what's his space if
that's the next thing I get to do it
would be amazing because it's the best
script I've ever read so how would that
work would that be like a one-off or
would it be a miniseries or ideally I
think we're hoping to do as a full part
TV series so we'll see you know I think
it's the kind of film that you know kind
of TV that we should be making this
country it's kind of challenging edge
and about something it's about you know
could have morality and it's about kind
of the last time that things were there
was a real kind of clash between the
left and right in this country but it's
all in the guise of a thriller in the
way that David Peter can can have really
an atomizer country but actually make it
incredibly entertaining as a huge you
like to see who would you like to be
directing in that well I'm hoping it's a
big cast I mean I've got a kind of dream
list that we've put together but I'd
love to work again with Jim Sturgess if
it have me he was in the last one we did
in ashes as one of the miners enough
you